let's say he's got a knife and he's just
stuff
unarmed officers arrive at belfair's
methodist church they're led into the
main hall
footage of what happened next has been
removed by police but the jury was shown
a man standing between the church pews
with a blood-stained knife
drop the knife
listen to me look it's only going to go
one way
the knife is dropped and they arrest him
prosecutors say this is ali harby alley
then being processed at south end police
station where officers ask if there was
a motive domestic
all right
the jury were also shown cctv images of
the defendant outside the houses of
parliament in september 2021 a month
before sir david amos was killed
ali appears at least seven times say the
prosecution
near parliament square and outside
downing street
on the 17th of september ali is spotted
near the constituency surgery of
finchley mp mike freya phone history
shows searches for future surgery events
and the mp's voting record
location data also places the defendant
outside the home of michael gove on at
least five occasions last summer trips
the prosecution say show ali preparing a
terrorist attack which he denies
police say on mobile phones found at the
scene in the defendant's home were
islamic state propaganda this encrypted
social media message from 2016
says one must wage jihad by himself with
the resources available to him knives
guns and explosives to kill the
crusaders and other disbelievers
another said kill them as they kill us
do not have mercy on them because they
are all the same
in court the prosecution showed the jury
the knife they believe was used to kill
sir david amos presented in a clear
see-through evidence box they say was
the weapon used to stab the mp more than
20 times
the 26 year old denies murder and denies
preparing acts of terrorism
the trial continues
ashnahara nags sky news at the old
bailey